foreign
[Music]
this is Ferguson Jonathan Ferguson the
keeper of firearms and artillery at the
Royal armors Museum in the UK which
houses a collection of thousands of
iconic weapons from throughout history
and this week he's taking a look at an
absolute classic of the genre the
original GoldenEye 007 okay this is this
is looking less like an MP5K than I
remember funnily enough the curvature of
the magazine all of that looks right and
so your brain overlooks the fact that
the receiver and the forehand look
absolutely nothing like an MP5K neither
does this
that's a firing port and that is a
trigger because in here
a d5k well an MP5K
if you like this kind of content we've
got a brand new season of Loadout airing
on the channel right now new episodes
are up every Sunday and you can check
out our most recent episode about the
weird ways games use calibers within
their virtual Arenas right let's take a
look at the iconic weapons from
GoldenEye
[Music]
so a real instant hit of nostalgia here
and uh being as it's the starting weapon
and the most iconic James Bond weapon of
all time the pp7 these are all going to
be an early example of Legally different
names of course the graphics don't
really lend themselves at this era two
super detailed depictions in terms of
likenesses but anyway the PPK of course
is what this really is uh in the Bond
movies it's often a PPK s which is the
380 ACP version that's a little bit
bigger this example I've picked for you
today from The Collection is uh you
probably won't be able to see it but
it's a PPK L this is a pretty rare
variant with a lightweight aluminum or
aluminum if you prefer frame so that's
the real example the other thing that
stands out for for me is the is that pew
pew sound with the suppressor attached
now we don't have any PPK threaded for
suppressor I don't think that was a
common thing to do in reality so that
sound effect
um done some research into that but the
very first appearance of that sound
effect is an obscure obscure today
anyway film called blue white and
perfect from 1942 and the sound engineer
for that movie created that classic
almost raygun sound effect
but it's just tremendous to see this
this game in action again and I'm
motivated to dig out the version of it
and play it again
[Music]
okay we've got a rifle we've got the the
kf7 Soviet which is quite far removed
from its real name easily recognizable
of course as the AK Clash nikov whatever
you'd like to call it I think on the
basis of the by modern standards very
crude front sight being a circle if you
can see that on this uh Chinese type 56
which is what this is I've chosen a type
56 to show you well also because in the
case of the folding stock version you
can sort of replicate the look of this
gun simply by folding the butt stock
this has got a nice original sling on it
as well like every other weapon in this
game I was blown away at the time in 97
when I saw such a well animated and
modeled and textured weapon cartridge
cases flying out the 3D amazing stuff
you know to me that was a well affected
accurate rendition of an AK the one
thing that did raise a little weird flag
in my brain for all the two-handed
weapons is the weirdness that if I
remember writing in third person you'd
see two hands on the gun but in first
person it waves around with one hand
which needless to say is not the way to
be able to hit anything if you're trying
to shoot
[Music]
foreign
now this is an interesting one I think
in my head this was always the wa2000
from The Living Daylights which we
featured before but actually of course
it isn't it is a conventionally laid out
sniper rifle but if you look at the
design it's pretty funky and I don't
know if at one point it was arranged in
a Bullpup configuration like the wa2000
and they actually didn't like the look
of it and uh flipped it around because
the way there's a sort of there's a sort
of metal shoe attaching a very chunky
wooden but to a pistol grip four stock
it really does look like an unbulp up
wa2000 to me maybe I'm reading into it
but there are certainly in the 90s there
wasn't I can't think of a sniper rifle
that really looks anything like this
this gun also suffers from of course
from the pew pew sound effect now if you
can you can make a small caliber pistol
like a PPK sound more like that actually
that sort of sound is actually the sound
you hear at the berm or wherever the
bullets are passing if you put a fast
moving bullet past the microphone you
can get a sound that sounds very very
much like the the choo choo sound you
can't really do that with a rifle bullet
for reasons well go and watch the the
loadout episode on suppressors because
we cover that in that episode
now this is a fascinating one back in 97
I had no idea what this was it is in
fact a real gun sights or sightings and
I can't remember Specter is the real gun
that this is actually really closely
based upon and if you're thinking well
it's not quite the right outline if we
deploy the stock NOW obviously there's
no stock on the gun we lock that in
place and then ignore it that is for the
graphics of this time spot on it even
has this this shape here to this
stamped steel receiver distinctive angle
the proportions are all correct the
angle of the magazine the different the
biggest difference is the color as far
as I know there is no white metal you
know uh in the white unfinished version
or Chrome or nickel or anything like
that but if you did
a nickel or metallic sort of silver
color coat the receiver on this gun it'd
be basically spot up at least for the
time really unusual gun really
interesting very cool very cold war and
by extension very Bond really
interesting gun uh really cool in the
game as well I think
foreign
[Music]
auto shotgun pretty primitive compared
to the the models for the other guns in
the game that didn't see a trigger or
trigger guard on there which the others
do have there's a fair bit of detail
actually given the limitations of early
3D Graphics whereas this is basically an
L shape although it does have some
nicely modeled cartridges in a side
saddle shell holder on the top of the
gun which gives it a nice look the four
ends I think probably what makes it look
less like a sparse is brown so Brown
equals wood in this this period of
graphics and the spars never had a
wooden floor end coming not too many
years after Doom and Doom 2 where you
just had could see your impacts on a
wall or on the enemies and it was the
first time you actually for me anyway
you actually felt like you had a
spreader shot that was having an effect
on doing something sort of visceral
Golden ice sort of in a way doesn't feel
as visceral because the those impacts
are like sparking they sort of you get a
sort of sparking effect but because it
had this quite realistic for the time
depiction of bloody gunshot wounds you
get both effects you get the the
slightly weird sparking and you get the
the red mark where the bullet hits and
then a load of quite realistic anime
death animations as well very surprising
for a Nintendo game at this time let me
tell you
[Music]
another weapon I had clean forgotten
about the rotary grenade launcher it's
very mgl maybe a bit of the old Enfield
R1 in there perhaps I can't remember if
that was in a Bond movie would make
sense if it had been I can't think of a
direct gun that this is based directly
upon barely ahead of its time with a by
animating the the drum rotating although
it seems to rotate a bit bit quickly
with the real guns you you shoot a
grenade either you release a trigger and
it Clockwork clicks to the next so or in
some way it moves after firing this
seems to move a bit quickly just
something I picked up on watching this
again slightly curious delay on the
effect on the enemies in that you'll get
a glorious explosion and then a bit
later they'll fall over
is of course with a real explosion the
blast wave if anything travels ahead of
the the fiery bit the fireball so it's
slightly curious which led to a weird
another weird situation where an
explosion goes off and it obviously has
a very tightly defined area of effect
and an enemy walks into that after the
fact and then died which again I don't
not something I remember seeing loads of
variety of the weapons in this game for
for the time tremendous amounts of
effort must have gone into this
oh
[Music]
right one of the more memorable guns in
the game for me apart because of the
name I guess and I know they use
developers names to to derive some of
these the the club
the VZ scorpion I did not remember that
the club in the game had the wire stock
modeled on the gun it's kind of curious
given that and some of the other details
that are on the guns in the game that so
many of the guns do not have a stock but
anyway we actually we have this
distinctively shaped stock it's not
functional of course but it does it
really reinforces that this is in fact
the Scorpion uh kind of it pretty much
behaves in the game not not exactly like
it does in real life obviously but in
terms of how it feels to the player I
say it's pretty close so I'm thinking
now about the the sound which I haven't
really mentioned so far for the time
great sound effects they're clearly not
recorded live or anything like that but
in relative terms they sound weaker than
the bigger guns you know they have they
have they haven't just used a stop
gunfire sound effect for everything as
would have been done for all bullet
firing weapons in most games at this
time the rate of fire is close enough to
be honest with you this thing has a
fairly impressive rate of fire reduced
system
built into its grip that slows this
thing down from what would probably be
about 1200 rounds per minute down to
much more controllable levels 750 or
something remember rightly so not a
million miles away from this so in terms
of How It's pitched in the GoldenEye
Arsenal it's really really good
good gun
[Music]
foreign
I've only got one scorpion out so I
can't I can't Jewel wield uh we do have
a Loadout episode of me all quickly
trying to Jewel we order that you should
definitely check out if you haven't
already do you know I'm not gonna set
myself up for for failure here by uh
attempting this but I think I probably
would have done better at that with a
pair of scorpions because the recoil of
that that cartridge is is lower than
something like the nine mil that we were
shooting the funny thing is firing
automatic once you start firing you can
adjust and correct and get your weapons
on Target and hold them there with a
weapon like this so I'm not saying this
is practical in any way but for you know
action movie-esque nonsense two
scorpions at the same time is somewhat
plausible don't try this at home kids
foreign
which you might think would be a legally
different hk33 but no this is of course
an M16 series weapon A2 hand guards not
detailed enough to say what model but I
think we can guess from Context and
period before anyone really knew what on
m16a3 was this is meant to be an m16a2
having said that there are different
types of m16a2 m16a2 is both the US
military designation for a certain model
or actually a couple of models
technically the one reason I'm burbling
about that is that I've brought to show
you a British service American-made
obviously but British service
m16a2 marked as such from 16a2 because
m16a2 was also a brand
from Colt so this is one that was
purchased for the British service it has
the A1
rear sight setup
uh it is automatic like the m16a3 in
American Navy service and apart from
that what makes it British and I have a
video on this on the Royal armories
Channel if you'd like a deeper dive
featuring this this exact gun black
paint finish serial number on the upper
receiver they're the main differences
not significant but it's our little
slice of the ArmaLite AR-15 history here
it's not bad for early 3D Graphics the
hand guard is looking a bit janky
certainly to to modernize the only sort
of criticism would be that the stock is
dropped now firstly that's one of the
design features of the armalites it's
meant to be an inline design so your
recoil is all happening along one line
which is great for controlling the
weapon and in term in technical terms
you have to do that anyway because the
recoil buffer your return spring
essentially is housed in a tube within
the stock so you could not have it down
here there are modern AR variants where
the spring is really located into the
receiver that's effectively what you'd
have to have here for this to work as to
why rare did this I would guess it's so
that in first person review the stock
isn't clipping through your vision I'd
forgotten that this has the rather
wonderful star-shaped muzzle flash that
Hollywood was obsessed with already by
this point which is it shouldn't be
possible with an A2 funnily enough
because then the ea2 has the solid
bottom to the bird cage flash suppressor
so you should not get that perfect star
shape you should get a partial star if
that it's not usually that visible
certainly not in daylight with Hollywood
they use blanks with an awful lot of
powder to precisely to get that
exaggerated effect and this is one of
the early-ish representations of that
very distinctive flash which is just
very cool
foreign
appearance of the fnp90 uh it's
certainly the first time I remember ever
seeing a P90 in a game even back then I
recognized it pretty much immediately as
a P90 this was the the latest coolest
gun it's pretty close in in silhouette
as it were the foregrip is separated
from the rear grip which is as we know
is not the case on the real gun that's
all one molding and um yeah the golden
Knight did pretty well it's got some
weird vertical ribbing on the butt that
isn't on a real gun I think I should put
that on there for for the sake of detail
might have been better if they wanted to
match the P90 if they'd put maybe just
one down the side to replicate the
Contour of the of the receiver I guess
the biggest departure here is this looks
like a
1960s version of the P90 with stamp
sheet metal and wooden I should get more
like 50s really wooden furniture and a
very funky looking magazine that then I
went yeah we talked before about the
evolution of the P90 magazine in games
and how it's got to the point now where
it essentially looks like the real thing
this of course looks couldn't really
look further from the real thing I don't
really know what they're going for with
that
[Music]
now seeing this thing back in Action
again reminds me that I suspect anyway
in the game the P90 is not using the
same feed system at all so that section
on top of the gun is not not meant to be
the magazine it's ventilated heat shield
almost like a smash 12 part of the
receiver and it's in a different bright
Metal finish but overall it's still the
right sort of configuration we have the
the metal straps effectively of the site
Mount Bridge the actual metal part of
the receiver that sits inside this
polymer stock that's represented
wrapping around what's the magazine on
the real gun so you still get the sense
that you're using a P90 I shouldn't
Overlook the 80 round capacity of the
fictional P90 50 rounds on the real gun
and of course the fact that it's spewing
out cartridge cases from the right hand
side uh just reinforces for me that it's
not either they just saw a picture of a
p19 went with that or they consciously
chose to Showcase their beautiful 3D
cartridge cases flying out of the gun
either way that's not how P90 works
[Music]
okay this is this is this is looking
less like an MP5K than I remember
funnily enough well it's got the right
proportions it's got a very well done
perfectly circular front sight protector
with no sighting of course Graphics
didn't support it really at that time
and the shape of the foregrip the little
it's even got the little finger stop at
the front the curvature of the magazine
all of that looks right and so your
brain overlooks the fact that the
receiver and the forehand look
absolutely nothing like an MP5K neither
does this
I'm sure some of you already know what
this is that's a firing Port that's a
safety catch and that is the trigger
because in here
we have
a d5k well an MP5K so designed to fire
from with inside the briefcase
operational briefcase and then uh if you
were in a protracted Bond style
firefight you open it up and out comes
your MP5K as you can see this does have
the the finger stop it has the uh the
ribbed shaped foregrip much simplified
of course the correct curvature for the
magazine
[Music]
Joe from first person view we don't
worry about the the rear sight being
missing we just see the the iconic
shaped HK front sight so yeah in terms
of the one-handed thing or the
inevitable dual wield again action movie
plausible the MP5 is a heavier weapon
than the Scorpion so it might be a bit
more fatiguing for your wrists but the
weight will help you keep it on target
if for whatever reason you're firing it
one-handed however the recoil of 9x19
although subjectively reduced in the MP5
still going to be significantly higher
than the Scorpion not to be recommended
you really need to be holding it with
both hands uh Push Pull method be very
cool for someone to mod in somehow uh
the operational briefcase and have you
fire it in HK fashion from under your
chin
foreign
[Music]
which appears to be Loosely based on the
rpg7 about the only rocket launcher
technically a recoilless weapon and with
a rocket assisted munition that I think
the developers would have been aware of
or I would have been aware of in 1997.
it's close enough to that I think for
recognition purposes it has a flared
it's a rear end not as pronounced as the
um Venturian blast tube on the back of
the the rpg7 and it's sort of the way it
steps down from narrower at the front to
thicker in the middle and even thicker
at the end it doesn't actually fit the
RPG that well but I think from the shape
and configuration of the of the iron
sights the fact it has a pistol grip I
think it's an rpg7 but it's pretty busy
looking it's got a lot of detail on
there that the real thing doesn't have
and it looks to be sort of all metal
obviously the RPG has the Bakelite
aspects to it yeah I think I think maybe
less attention has been paid to this in
terms of what it is it's more more of a
generic video game weapon than most of
the others
[Music]
foreign
interesting choice for a Magnum revolver
and although the proportions are pretty
squiffy you can see a lot of the
diagnostic features of this the Ruger
Blackhawk especially in this satin
finish the shape of the front sight and
its base the shape of the frame
especially the um well it's not uncommon
on revolvers but all the basic facets
are there the hammer is has gone a bit
awry but we do have a separately model
cylinder which which is somewhat
impressive the wooden grips they're a
weird shape on the on the GoldenEye
version they're much more than the
plowshare shape of the traditional
Single Action Army on the original
Blackhawk but they are meant to be
wooden grips the Blackhawk somehow is
double action in in Goldeneye I couldn't
remember this that detail so it was one
I was waiting for and but we do see the
hammer animated which is quite
impressive actually but it is magically
being cocked and released by the trigger
finger which is not possible with a
single action trigger mechanism unless
it is also a double action Dragon
mechanism something I haven't mentioned
so far is the other reloads in Goldeneye
where Anthony you simply lower the gun
off camera you hear a click and your gun
is reloaded so it's heavily fudged in
the game which was a again sort of a
technical thing I guess in that 2D
animations have got somewhat
sophisticated showing magazines or
shotgun shells or whatever being loaded
into a weapon and cases cases flying out
we have cases flying out we don't have
reloads so click and it's and it's full
again
foreign
[Music]
ER laser probably my least favorite gun
in the game although it is somewhat
faithful to Bond Law although I'm not
sure Moonraker is anyone's favorite Bond
movie The Original prop for the for the
film as I'm sure some of you have
spotted was a an easy full-size IMI Uzi
sub machine gun painted white with some
stuff stuck to it does a fairly good job
breaking up the outline which is
probably why the GoldenEye version looks
about right proportions wise but has no
real hint of the uzi that was underneath
the the disguise Parts in the movie
wow
[Music]
the Golden Gun of course that's from the
that's from the straight out of one of
the movies as well of course in the in
its original movie context it's uh sort
of disguised Weapon made from different
parts I believe the the armor is all the
prop Master rather went to a cigarette
lighter manufacturer in order to to
create the thing pretty fascinating bit
of movie history in this footage you can
actually see my favorite thing about the
guns of GoldenEye which was the ability
to aim your gun anywhere on the screen
with one of the thumb sticks something
that's almost never been done since just
love that it's limiting in in many ways
for for modern FPS Shooters FPS players
but uh at the time I just love the
ability to move with one stick and shoot
anywhere on the screen instinctively
which felt a lot like something I've
never tried in real life which is point
shooting where this was torched to the
Commandos among others you look where
you shoot and the game effectively
simulated doing that very critical to be
able to do that for me with golden gun
because you have that one round before
you go to your reload and you say you
only get that one critical shot
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for watching guys we
appreciate it these were the guns of
GoldenEye one of my all-time favorite
video games if you're in the UK or are
sufficiently crazy to come to the UK
specifically for this there is an event
going on on the 11th of March where if
you pay the ticket you'll be able to
have a bit of a meet and greet with me
and there's all sorts of other stuff
going on that weekend around a theme of
historic Firearms a new batch of tickets
is being released imminently I believe
or may have been already by the time you
see this in any case uh love to see you
again next week
[Music]
foreign